منشات تجاريه واقتصاديه وحيويه في قلب
روسيا تستهدف بمسيارات وطائرات دون طيار
تحلق قرب الكريم ومطارات في العاصمه تتوقف
عن العمل لبضع ساعات لماذا تكثف كييف من
استخدام المسيرات في استهداف العمق الروسي
صحيفه
في تقرير لها ان الهدف الاهم لاستخدام
كياف مسيرات في ضرب روسيا هو تفنيد ما
يصفها الرئيس الروسي بالعمليه العسكريه
الخاصه وان رساله كييف الاهم لموسكو هي ان
الحرب باتت في عمق روسيا وان العاصمه
موسكو ليست خارجه نطاق الاستهداف وتضيف
الصحيفه ان الضربات الاوكرانيه وان لم
تلحق خسائر مباشره بالاهداف لكن تاثيرها
غير المباشر يكون في نزع الشع بالامن عن
رواد الاعمال والمواطنين الروس على
المستوى التكتيكي يقرا خبراء ارتفاع وتيره
الهجمات الاوكرانيه كدليل على قدرتكيف على
تصميم وسائل ردع حتى وان كانت محدوده
التاثير
فكيف تطالب منذ اشهر بتسليمها طائرات اف
16 بما يسمح لها بتوفير غطاء جوي للقوات
الاوكرانيه اثناء التقدم برا اضافه للدفاع
عن خطوط شحن البحريه وتامين استئناف تصدير
الحبوب الاوكرانيه يبقى ان احد اهداف
اوكرانيا من تكثيف استخدام المسيرات قد
يكون محاوله لدفع الجيش الروسي الى اعاده
نشر قواته لحمايه الداخل لكن صحيفه
الجاردين البريطانيه تشير انه لا دلائل
حتى الان تشيي بان روسيا اعادت او انها
على وشك اعاده تموضوع
وكانت تقارير روسيه كشفت في وقت سابق ان
موسكو انشات حقل رادارات غربيه البلاد
مهمتها رصد الاهداف التي تحلق على
ارتفاعات منخفضه والاهداف الصغيره
كالمسيره
وبحسب مختصين فان الرادارات يمكنها اكتشاف
الطائرات القادره على التخفي على مسافه
ثلاثه الاف كيلو متر وعمليات اطلاق صواريخ
كروز او الطائرات التي تفوق سرعتها سرعه
الصوت على مسافه 2000 كيلو متر عن الحدود
الروسيه